What do you want Rangiora to look and feel
like in 10, 20 or 30 years’ time?
People love to live here and we’re growing
rapidly.
By 2048, more than 30,000 people will call
Rangiora home.
We’re now planning for the town’s ongoing
growth and success and we want your ideas.
As new neighbourhoods emerge, we need to think
about:
Building the right type of housing
Developing new parks and greenspaces
Providing areas for shops and community facilities
and tying it all together with great options for driving, walking, cycling and public transport.
We also need to make sure the Rangiora Town Centre continues to develop successfully
and has room to expand.
How can we build on our centre to create a
vibrant, attractive place where people enjoy
living, working and spending their free time?
Help us shape Rangiora’s future by telling
us what you want to see happen!
Tell us your ideas at waimakariri.govt.nz/Rangiora